today's goal is I want to basically go
through sort of some of the key steps I
want to go through some of the key steps
it's sort of like what it takes to
actually make an AI product and I think
that one of the things I see is a lot of
people learn how to do em miss they
learn how to build a basic model they
learn to do stuff you know maybe in
Jupiter notebooks but then they don't
think about actually sort of taking a
basic model and transforming that into
an actual AI product I so I want to sort
of discuss some of the real-world
challenges and I'm actually gonna do it
with a real-world example that I built I
about ten days ago all right so I gave
this talk last weekend in in Bangkok the
day there and I built this just a couple
days before that so it you'll see how it
goes anyway um so Google pretty much all
of googles products now contain some
form of machine learning or deep
learning I one of the classic examples
was there's this slide that's actually
very old now this is almost coming out
in almost two years old that shows the
the number of repositories inside Google
that basically have a a machine learning
or deep learning or ideally tensorflow
in that repository and it's well over
6,000 now I think it's getting close to
7,000 or more already and basically you
know deep learning is now being used
inside Google for all these different
products and certainly the reason why I
sort of show this is to show you that
you know Google is definitely leading
the way but everyone else is following
behind and you're gonna see more and
more that most products that are sort of
digital products in some way will will
use machine learning you've got
companies like Netflix who are making
extensive use of this sort of technology
you've got all different sort of fields
you know doing that so what I wanted to
do today was basically look at okay what
are some of the challenges that you have
when you're building you know an AI
product and the first one I may sound a
bit silly but this is one of the most
important ones I think is that just can
it be done is it something that's even
possible so we get a lot of people
asking us you know
or can you build something that does X
which is just you know like can you
build something that you know they might
as well be saying can you build
something that can read people's minds
and then predict the stock market and do
all 25 other things in one shot
right um and so the big thing you want
to do is say like okay is it possible
and so one of the other things you want
to ask yourself to sort of justify that
question is has someone else done it
before I
another big and sometimes you will see
that you know just because someone
hasn't done it before doesn't mean you
should you know stop i but you should be
wary of you know things that maybe
haven't been done before I is there data
available I think this is one of the key
questions that we're constantly asking
clients or people that we work with is
you know you find time and time again
that what people want to do is actually
quite doable if they had the right data
and you sort of end up saying to them
well your business could collect this
data but you need to go away now and
click this data for the next six months
to 12 months and then come back with it
before we can sort of do something with
it the other thing other sort of
questions you ask yourself is like okay
can you find or synthesize the data
especially if you are a start-up you're
often not gonna have a lot of data at
the start so you're going to be looking
for ways to synthesize data right and
you know some of the key things I just
want to point out was that these sort of
ways of looking at things are very
different than sort of just building a
model to learn about machine learning
and also it's very different than
academic sorts of things of building up
you know a paper to be at nips or
something like that I so the way I like
to think about it is can this task be
broken down into component parts one of
the biggest sort of myths is that people
think that okay just because they learn
about end-to-end models that in industry
everything then to end usually not the
case right usually you have different
parts or different models doing
different things the other question or a
lacrosse is okay what's your problem
like is it a classification problem is
it a regression problem is it a
generative problem I hate you'd be
surprised that a lot of things that will
look a certain way can be sort of
refracted or changed too
a different way I example of this would
be smart reply inside Google so the
first you know paper for smart reply or
first of all this started out as
basically an April Fool's joke
in 2009 the okay Google made this
product that would just reply to your
emails then people started to think
about okay well maybe this could be done
and the first sort of academic papers
that we're looking at this would use it
doing it as a sequence the sequence
generative model so it would basically
read your your subject line it would
read the text of your email and then
based on that it would generate a bunch
of text for a reply the problem with
this was that it would generate three
replies and it turned out almost always
that one of the three replies was I love
you because it was just safe right and
the model learned that okay if it put
that you know that was a safe response
for a large proportion of things um to
get to the actual sort of production
version and again this is an older slide
I think actually smart reply now on
mobile makes up about 30% of all replies
I the it needed to be changed and what
happened was they actually changed it to
be coming from moving from a generative
problem to being a classification
problem that it basically looks at your
email and decides okay for these
responses I will pick one of 29,000
different classes so it's a very it's
moving from something that's sort of
infinite to something that's very finite
and you know I must admit when when we
first heard about this we were quite
disappointed because the academic paper
was so amazing at the time that we
thought oh wow if Google's actually got
this working this is gonna you know this
is could be a really big step along the
way to you know a whole bunch of
different products but it turned out in
the end that okay i it was just turned
into a classification problem and this
is something that's very common in when
you're building products like AI
products for the real world
something that will seem to be sort of
like totally generative when it actually
makes it out into the real world it
becomes very um you know becomes a
classification or something much sin
than what it was in the academic sense
so okay this is what I wanted to start
out doing so I remember reading about
this paper I don't know if you guys read
about this last year and I thought oh
this is really cool at some point I
would like to do this so probably about
two weeks ago I started actually reading
the paper and thinking okay well how am
I you know gonna implement it look at
some of the examples that were out there
and what this basically is is you draw a
picture of a website and it turns it
into code right and it basically just
takes your drawing and it works out okay
how will it represent that in HTML I and
this is quite this is the paper that it
came from I and the original worm was
was picked to code where they basically
tried to do for HTML I they did it for I
think XML for for iOS displays and and
for Android displays for me I just
focused on the HTML part now one of the
first questions I always ask myself is
well what is this like what is what kind
of you know what kind of problem is this
going to be compared to other things
that I've seen in the past so the
classic one I that this is like is
basically like image captioning so you
may have seen this you know a year or
two back the whole show-and-tell
concept of where you basically train up
a model so that it looks at the image
and it writes a caption based on what it
sees in that image I and you can see
that it's pretty amazing that it has the
ability to look at this picture and even
though we can't sort of see any any sort
of string or anything between the human
and the kite the model is able to work
out that okay if the person's facing the
kite if the kites a certain height in
the air then it probably is a person
flying the kind and given enough data
you know both images and enough captions
it has the ability to you know to you
build the model so that has the ability
to learn to do this so this is something
that man and I were both very interested
in a bit over a year back now and
actually Martin showed a good example of
doing this with a
what's become now famous paper attention
is all you need and our tensorflow
Meetup
so I encourage you to come along because
often we show very cutting-edge things
there so this is the first thing it's
that I thought okay well this paper is
kind of like this the second one is that
the whole idea of that if you basically
use some sort of RNAi Norrell STM you
can generate a config file so the slide
here comes from a paper called neural
architecture search which basically led
to Nazz net right which James was
talking about you know this current
state of the art in image image net
models is nez net and the way that this
model worked was i can't go into all the
detail but one of the key parts of it
was that it basically had this iron end
controller that would predict certain
parts which would then become like a
config file which would then get turned
into basically a network so for example
you can see there it's got like the
number of filters
so here it's predicting one layer of a
CNN and it's basically deciding the
number of filters the HUD the filter
height filter width you're striding I
and what do we do then is it would
basically take that just very quickly
about nez net what it would do is it
would take that it would then build the
model train it up and then check the
accuracy score and then use
reinforcement learning back to feed into
the RNN as a reward thing I so then over
time it would change but the key concept
here is that I was interested in was
this concept of basically you can take
some sort of RNN and you can use it to
make a config file and that config file
could be used then to build something
like an HTML file and so another thing
that this could be like that you can
think of is I some I'm sure many of you
have played around with Chow RNAs how
many people know the model chart are in
in where you basically build a recurrent
neural network to predict the next
character of text and maybe you've done
it with Shakespeare or maybe you've done
it with you know some sort of text and
that you find that after a certain
number iterations the model has the
ability to actually predict readable
text after a while
so these are the things that I started
out thinking well this problem is kind
of like that because we're taking a
picture and we're going to turn it into
some sort of config file which I'm then
going to turn into an HTML file so let
me sort of explain a little bit about
yeah about all the the things so there's
key to key sort of bits of data that
we're gonna import we're gonna input
images and we're gonna we're gonna input
sort of gooey convicts
so the GUI config on I'll show you a
picture one later on is basically just a
representation of an HTML page in a much
simpler format then the model that I'm
gonna use for this is basically a
convolutional neural network going into
one of these LS TM s so we're gonna
basically a you know extract features
and then go into that I GU e file is
basically going to become sort of like
our vocabulary that we're predicting I
and then last of all we're gonna use
really something that's not deep
learning base but just simple coding
base is this compiler and this compiler
will basically take our predictions out
and then use those predictions to turn
them into a proper HTML file so another
way if you can look at this is you've
got your CNN you're seeing in you can
think of as being like a feature
extractor it's looking at that
hand-drawn image and it's trying to
determine okay what are the key features
in in here then that's going to make the
configs and so it so then we also make
some configs and we tokenize them we
then put both of those into a model to
basically train an LST m to come out of
this i and then last of all what we're
gonna do is as we're coming out we're
using a soft max just to simply predict
we're turning this into classification
now simply predict what is the next
token based on what we've seen already
so i and then we take those tokens where
we call those tokens a domain-specific
language and we convert those to HTML so
let's actually look at sort of a picture
of the model architecture so here you
can sort of see we've basically got an
LS
and a CNN going into an LST m and that's
going to predict our domain-specific
languages and our tokens in that case
then we're going to basically wait at
you know when we're doing inference
we're just literally going to put in the
the image itself and rely on that to
extract the features and to bring those
out into our sort of LST m and that's
going to make the al config file so
another key problem is I've kind of
touched on this already is the compiler
so this is sort of like a real trick of
of the trade that you see for a lot of
these sorts of things and that if we
were you know how many of you know LST M
is an hour and ends quite a lot right
okay good so if you've dealt with LSD ms
and our own ends you know that they have
a very limited amount of prediction
power meaning that there's no way we
could really train in LS TM to predict
you know a thousand characters of an
HTML file it's just not going to be that
you know accurate at doing it and it's
certainly gonna fail at things like
learning to open and close different
tags or learning to do that kind of
thing I so we need to produce this sort
of config file that's what I was showing
you before with the nez net slide and
then we have this domain-specific
language these tokens that are gonna
represent and be compiled into the raw
HTML stuff right so this is what an
example of a config file looks like so
each one of these is a separate token
that basically the network is getting
going to be able to predict now of
course remember we you know these are
going to be then tokenized and turn into
numbers and fit in and but when we turn
those not when we make the prediction
out of numbers coming back out this is
what we want to get something like this
and you can see this is going to start a
start token and end token so any of you
work with you know any sort of NLP and
deep learning or any sort of sequence
the sequence stuff this should be quite
similar to those things you've seen
before we then take that gooey
and we basically have to then use a
template to basically turn that back
into the HTML and so this GUI basically
you know this config file just
represents chunks and snippets of HTML
if you think about that and it's just
going to basically stick it all together
and one of the things that we need to
have though is a template file so we
have a template file that is mapping
from those tokens that we're predicting
to actual raw HTML in this case and you
can see that we've got for example an
opening tag a closing tag I we've got
you know different things for header for
a button for you know a few different
things like that
ok data now this is where this becomes a
real challenge I is that synthesizing
data is you know one of the biggest
challenges you're gonna have in making
any sort of AI product I usually you're
gonna have to find some way to make data
at scale if you're gonna make a
commercial product it's been it's it's
big it's very well known secret I think
that Google Baidu Facebook etc often
will make products just simply to gather
data right this has become very
controversial obviously with a lot of
the things going on with Facebook
recently I but you know and your own has
talked about this that I do there are a
number of products that they've made
with no intention of making any money on
that product that it's a lost leader
purely to gather data I and if you can
do something like that for your
particular situation that's something
you definitely want to do this will
usually be one of the biggest challenges
you face in making you know AI products
I you then also often have to build your
own tools to annotate data or to be able
to you know find some way of tagging
data another thing I don't have time to
go into today but you can also use some
sort of unsupervised learning or
semi-supervised learning way to actually
take sort of raw data from the wild and
you know label that or turn that into
something obviously the more data the
better but the data must simulate you
know in this case for example the data
had to simulate what
someone might draw and another just
really sort of simple tip is that this
model crunches that image right down
but when you're gathering data try and
get it at the highest resolution
possible because you never know when
you're gonna want something that's
higher res and in this case I actually
got two of my staff to just sit there
for two days and draw pictures right to
get the data and if I had been gone back
to them and said oh sorry the image is
not you know high-res enough they
wouldn't even pretty pissed off at me
having to do that again I but you know
yeah so like you do in this case we
needed a lot of hand-drawn stuff so one
of the things I did try with this which
didn't work was trying out different
sort of CSS you know styles or different
ways of actually making it so this is
sort of one of the things that I found
on code pen was a way to basically try
and make buttons look like they were
hand-drawn in the end though this didn't
seem to work at the at you know for what
we were trying to do I if I was doing
this probably further on I would maybe
look at maybe even building our own sort
of CSS stuff to make some way of being
able to just suddenly turn out you know
a hundred thousand web pages but what we
did was drew draw them so these are some
examples I from from a test set the
train sets basically the same sort of
you know very sort of similar sort of
stuff and you can see that the idea is
just to get an understanding of okay
where the key parts of the layout of the
website go
so prototyping okay the next thing once
you've got your data once you're
starting to build the model you know
you've got to stop then thinking about
prototyping stuff so I you want to map
out the sort of product workflow you
want to sort of keep about you know I
you know creating each part of it and
stuff like that the big thing you want
to do though is you just want to get
something working ideally for me it's in
a Jupiter notebook so that then I have
something that I can basically you know
take two people and and show you know
the basic chairs
to see does this work or does this not
work the other key thing though you want
to think about is and having in the back
of your mind is okay what's going to be
my end UI for this product what am I
actually going to how people actually
going to interact with this product so
let's have a look
how's that for size
okay so this is the sort of prototype
that I put together for in a Jupiter
notebook so I'll walk you through it
well we basically I so I built the model
right I've got the model I'm just
loading the model I did the whole thing
in Cara's just to show that you can
build something like this in quite a
simple thing as Kerris Hey and certainly
I would encourage you if your using
tensorflow and you're new to tensorflow
use Karis right it's very simple to
start out with as you get better at it
you think graduate to other things so
we've got our model all right I'm gonna
load up I an image here and here is the
here's the image now you can see that
what I'm actually doing is crunching the
image down to actually just 256 by 256
so when I try building different
versions of the model at the start I
used very similar to what James was
talking about he was using transfer
learning and I built basically you know
I just started out using different
models well 3 start using different
models to see like okay what would work
in the end it turned out that the image
type models were probably a bit too
complicated for the feature extractor
that I needed so I went with a sort of
simpler Network but I stuck with the you
know the whole sort of size just like
the paper where they stuck with the 256
by 256 and three channels deep in this
case so then we've got the the tokens so
these are the tokens I've got and you
can see basically now I'm just doing a
sort of lookup table to map the token to
a number which I'm going to feed in I
then need some some way of actually sort
of generating those you know those those
predictions so basically what we're
doing for those of you are not used to
this sort of model system I'm basically
making a prediction of one number then
I'm passing that number back in to the
network to predict the next number so
I'm predicting one after the other so I
will get a sequence all right and you
will see that actually here so if I if I
run this we can see that what it's doing
is it's predicting each one out now its
base
predicting that as a number I'm using
the lookup table to change it back to
the GUI in this case I I been just right
so then that's really the key
you know the key sort of deep learning
part has already happened there we've
basically extracted the features from
what we passed in I'm saving it and then
I basically got the compiler set up to
actually generate it into HTML and this
is the HTML that it it generates let me
look oh this is what this is our
prediction let's see how did it compare
to what we put in not bad okay so if you
were like me you'd be very suspicious
that all Sam picked wonder it's just
going to work so what I did then was I
basically thought well okay really we
should I really want this in some sort
of web form or we want some way that
people can draw it so I'm gonna do one
on the fly and I'm gonna be drawing on
my trackpad so it's not going to be very
good but let's say
I draw a few buttons and this doesn't
always work because it's still very much
in prototype phase three or four buttons
let's go for four all right and there I
want to have sort of one long box
not exactly neat we have a heading we
want a bunch of checks there oh I hope
we have a button I tell what actually
that's too similar to the one that we
already did so let's add some more stuff
we can add
now you'll notice that one of the things
I've got in here that I've actually
added in is the page style so we can
actually then sort of say to this we can
pass in an argument or a condition of
what type of paint you know what type of
page do we want this to be so that
really relates to sort of like the CSS
that we want to pass in so I'm going in
for the first one I'll do bootstrap and
then basically press my create HTML and
you can see this is definitely not as
neat as the one that you know the wood
the training examples or this even the
test examples okay let's press it and
see all right so did you get the buttons
right yes when I did it last week it
added an extra button position I'll just
quickly go along and show you though we
could actually add even more to this I
so the model can actually take you know
quite a bit and this is sort of just to
talk about this while I'm doing drawing
you want to sort of stress test your
product right in the real world people
would you know I'm not gonna draw nice
and neat all right so there's no point
in sort of trying to you know draw an e
or anything like that you want to
basically I do it as as as much as a
real-world scenario will do and this is
one of the challenges that I see with
things like you know I work a lot in
things to do with dialog and stuff I and
people when they build chat BOTS will
think that humans are gonna respond one
way and humans respond a totally
different way all right so you always
want to try and gather as much data as
you can from the wild and actually one
of the things I actually put into this
is that every time I draw something here
or every time it basically we create an
HTML page we actually save the image as
well
so that then if we were looking at it
and saw that okay it got this one right
it got this one wrong
I could actually go back and sort of use
those as training data for things going
forward and this is a really common sort
of thing for I you know that Google does
that a lot of other big companies do so
let's try material design I don't know
how well it's gonna do with material
design all right all right
let's to create HTML stinking thing
another challenge with this is is that
okay for example this response time is
just way too slow for the real world so
if I was gonna release this as a you
know as a startup or as a product or
something like that I would definitely
need to be looking at optimizing for
speed all right you get it all right yes
okay um let me go back to the
presentation so where to from here so
okay I now got you know something that's
a prototype if I wanted to take this
into production there would be a whole
bunch of different considerations to
think about and this is where you're
going to be working with product
managers with you know other types of
people who are maybe not not gonna know
a lot about the deep learning or your
machine learning or any that sort of
tech but for example this product would
this product be better as a mobile
product versus a web product in some
ways I think I could probably sell this
as maybe an iPad app all right you know
or something like that I or what this
product might be good is making an iPad
app for some sort of web hosting
services to give away for free but it
only generates you know files that work
on their web hosting that kind of thing
you want to think about I you know micro
services versus monoliths I'm not going
to talk about that much today but
generally you want to sort of with a lot
of these sorts of things you would want
to have you know the test flow running
on maybe a micro service or intensively
serving like James talked about you
would want to think about okay they're
gonna use a GPU or not obviously when I
was the reason why I was taking so long
is I was doing the inference on my CPU
here so therefore it was taking a lot
longer to to actually work if I was
doing that with
Jib you in the cloud I could get the
speed much quicker but then also I need
to think about you know the cost per API
call I and especially if I'm doing
something at scale those sorts of things
become really important your model size
you always want to be optimizing for
smaller models faster models one of the
tricks for doing that we don't have a
lot of time to talk about today is you
often train a big model and then you
train another smaller model to learn
from the big model alright and that's
that's a way of being able to get around
a lot of those things so if I was doing
a mobile version of this I I definitely
want to be using something like tensor
light or Core ml if I wanted to make it
for you know I could also then add in
the bits for iOS or Android meaning that
I could actually make layouts for
Android apps or for iOS apps one of the
things I wouldn't personally do this so
I actually I had a lot of experience in
mobile certainly on iOS knowing he
really uses the stock you know Apple
widgets anymore people tend to make
their own so I kind of feel like that
wouldn't be a big advantage in doing
that sort of thing if I was banging it
for the cloud where would you know where
would I deploy those HTML pages to at
the moment it's still just all running
local business considerations
um just now and this is what I think is
really important just because you can
make something as technically great
doesn't mean people will use it and I
actually kind of feel that this this
particular product falls into that
category I that I kind of feel like it's
a really cool gimmick and it you know it
looks really cool but how many people
would actually use it to design the
website probably not many right so you
always want to be thinking about will
you know will people pay for this I see
this all the time when I'm you know
mentoring startups and stuff that I say
often they will make something that's
maybe technically very great but really
in the real world is no one's gonna pay
for that product again you know is it a
painkiller is the vitamin it's kind of
you know does the ml or a I shine more
than the actual product this case I
think it does and I think perfect
example is like when I show to you guys
you understand that oh there's a lot of
you know hardcore deep learning going on
there I show to the average person on
the street and it may get one button
wrong and they like I'd sucks it right
oh so you want to sort of think about
you know those sorts of things from a
more research perspective the other
thing that I think would be really cool
for this is you could actually develop
again to do this this is maybe something
I will play around with in the future
you can actually build again for both
making training images and also for
making the different types of gooeys I
you could also build a really cool
system to be able to basically just go
out and crawl current websites and use
that to make training data for you so
that people could actually you know do
things another thing is that I would
definitely want to add more tags to this
so at the moment I don't have any sort
of image tag so really what I should do
is have a box with maybe a cross through
it and that would be showing that okay
we want an image there or something like
that anyway some tricks of the trade
I follow Google's example play to your
strengths I google is definitely the
king of search and they tend to turn
things into a search problems as much as
possible
I why I've signed a number of MBAs with
Google I can't tell you you know sort of
anything secret but I would say that you
know one of the things that we've
definitely learned over time is that
Google will often turn things into a
rank and retrieve problem or some sort
of search problem rather than just a
straight out prediction problem so
that's something that you should you
know definitely think about and
obviously Google home really is just a
big massive search engine in many ways I
play to your data make things that you
either have the data for can get the
data fork and steal the data or can
create it I this is by far you know
we're not when you see AI startups and
stuff like that the it really comes down
to okay do they have the data do they
have a unique set of data that will
allow them to do this sort of stuff
medical data can be really hard to get
yet so many people I see trying to do
the medical thing and the radiography
thing really win a lot of the models now
are just becoming like off-the-shelf you
can take the best model from Cargill
it's really comes down to who's got the
data to you know be able to implement
that I getting millions of examples of
something that you need from the public
is really really hard so that's
something that you also want to think
about and that's it I'm happy to take
some questions there's some links to the
original paper and original
implementation of the paper as well